>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Audie Cornish: Hello everybody.
We can be a little louder than that.
I think it's almost noon right?
[laughter] Hello everybody.
[applause] My name is Audie Cornish
and I host NPR's "All
Things Considered."
[ Applause ]
And I am a sometime panelist
on NPR's Pop Culture Podcast,
"Pop Culture Happy Hour"
and, like you, a book lover.
NPR is a media partner this year
with the National Book Festival.
We want to thank the co-chairman
of the festival, David Rubenstein,
and the many National Book
Festival partners like the ARP.
Thank you so much.
Now today we're going
to have a conversation
with two amazing writers.
It's not my idea to put
them in the same room.
So, whoever's idea it was,
let's say thank you to them.
Winston Groom, author of the
forthcoming novel, "El Paso."
Winston Groom.
Winston Groom was DC
born and Alabama raised
and he's mined history for
much of his writing career,
from his first novel, set
during the Vietnam War,
to his non-fiction works like,
"Shrouds of Glory," about one
of the final campaigns
of the Confederate Army,
and of course you might have
heard of a little book called
"Forest Gump," popularized by
the motion picture that followed.
It's a romp through
boomer generation history,
told through the eyes of a
southern man with a knack for being
in the right place
at the right time.
Now Winston Groom comes
to us today on the eve
of publishing his latest book,
"El Paso," and that book --
you'll need this for the
rest of the conversation --
is set during the early
1900s during the great war,
the Mexican Revolution,
when an American railroad tycoon
finds his family kidnapped
and his Mexican cattle
business under siege
by a cut-throat revolutionary.
That book is out in early October.
Winston Groom, welcome to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Winston Groom: Thank
you very much.
[inaudible]
>> Audie Cornish: Yes.
[ Applause ]
Our second author is
Colson Whitehead,
who is a New Yorker,
born and raised.
[applause] Colson Whitehead has
made his mark basically dancing in
and out of genres; a zombie
apocalypse in the novel "Zone One,"
corporate culture satire
in "Apex Hides the Hurt,"
and a myth-busting turn in
the novel "John Henry Days."
He joins our stage today
having just published
"The Underground Railroad."
That's the story that imagines;
what if the network of former slaves
and abolitionists that helped
runaways leave the South had an
actual underground train?
The book is out everywhere [laughs]
including Oprah's Book Club.
Colson Whitehead, welcome
to the stage.
[ Applause ]
So, I have a little bit of
housecleaning before we start.
Number one; this is your opportunity
to turn your cellphones off
and think about the questions
you might have towards the end.
We are going to have a Q and
A. So, to start I want to ask
with something that I noticed in the
start of your book, Winston Groom,
which is that you said, "This
is not a historical novel
in any conventional sense."
[laughs] So, tell us -- define that.
What, to you, does it
mean to do a historical --
>> Winston Groom: Well, I -- when I
think of a historical book I think
of like "Prince Valiant"
or something.
[laughs] This is historical
characters
that I used to move my story along.
It was a historical setting
that I wanted because of a story
that a friend of mine
told me about his father.
My friend was a Morgan, [assumed
spelling] a New York Morgan,
and not -- it was a different
family from JP, they were cousins.
But they were quite wealthy
and in the late 1800s they owned
an enormous cattle ranch in Mexico,
in the state of Chihuahua.
The elder Mister Morgan, who
had been, I believe the Governor
of New York, used to take his
private railroad car down there
to inspect his quarter of a million
head of cows, or whatever it was.
Unfortunately in 1916 the
American Revolutionary bandit,
General Poncho Villa, had begun to
depredate these American holdings
down there and he in fact
-- my friend's story was --
he took the manager of the farm, of
the cattle ranch, and he strung him
up and he sabered him --
had him sabered to death --
he kidnapped two of his children.
And so that story captivated me
to the extent that I've thought
about it for 20 years and I made
-- I wrote on it for 20 years,
but I could never get it right
until about a year and a half ago.
I threw everything aside and
fooled with it, but what I have
in the story is that
it is the grandchildren
of this wealthy railroad
baron -- he's not a Morgan,
I changed his name -- but
to make it a short story,
as you do in Hollywood -- if you
going to pitch a movie they say,
"Pitch it in the space that it
takes to take an elevator ride."
So, to make a long story short, it
took about 400 and something pages
and 300 and something of
them concern a manhunt
through the high Sierras to try to
get back these kidnapped children.
>> Audie Cornish: And this manhunt
takes place in Northern Mexico
and throughout the book they
sprinkle real-life characters --
you sprinkle real-life characters;
John Reed and Ambrose Pearson
and names from the period.
Colson Whitehead, I want
to ask you, with your book,
"The Underground Railroad," it
kind of mimics a slave narrative
in that it's told from the point
of view of one particular slave
for much of the book and you
don't necessarily draw names
from the period.
Am I correct about that?
It's a little bit of
an alternate universe.
>> Colson Whitehead: Yes,
I mean it starts off,
hopefully in a realistic 1850,
and then, you know, the premise is
that the Underground Railroad
is an actual railroad.
And so you're already departing
from reality, as far as I know,
and it's not straight historical.
And then each state our
protagonist goes through --
South Caroline, North Caroline --
is a different state of
American possibility,
sort of like "Gulliver's Travels."
So, definitely the later chapters
don't stick to historical record
and for the most part aren't
inspired by real folks,
although real events do inform what
happens to our protagonist, Cora.
But I did want the first section
that takes place on the plantation
where Cora lives and works and
has many troubles to be realistic
and take place in a -- I guess
what most people would call
in a historical novel
-- imaginative space.
>> Audie Cornish: And I just want
to make it clear; this does not feel
like science fiction
when you're reading it.
I had -- I read, you know,
the first chapter of your book
and I just put it down for
five days because it was sort
of -- it was pretty intense.
And I think when you go back into
these periods writers, I assume,
in your research look for, I
guess totems or actual artifacts
from the period that
help inform your work.
And for you, can you list some
of the things that you found
that helped you inform sort of
how you went about the story?
>> Colson Whitehead: Sure, yeah.
I mean there are a
few general histories
of the Underground Railroad --
"Bound for Canaan" by
Fergus Bordewich came
out about eight years ago --
but my main source were the
actual slave narratives --
pre Civil War; Fredrick
Douglass, Harriot Jacobs,
sort of the famous ones, and then
in the 1930's; FDR being a nice guy,
trying to get people back
to work during the Great
Depression had the Works Progress
Administration and they sent out
writers to interview former slaves,
people who had been kids
or teenagers at the time
of the Civil War and then that
was like my biggest resource.
I drew a lot of slang and
words, physical details
about how they lived, which really
made the work come alive for me.
You know I'll know before a story
what kind of clothes they wore
or food they ate, you come across
a reference to an ash cake.
It's like; what's an ash cake?
That sounds terrible.
And then you read up on it.
It's like; that's actually it's
worse than you really thought.
[laughter] So, you
know, as I was going
through these oral narratives
I would just take out nouns
and adjectives, things that sounded
great, and then when it was time
to write I would have
this storehouse
of vocabulary to make it rich.
>> Audie Cornish: Winston Groom,
for you similarly; this is a period
of American history and a
region that people don't talk
so much about, these
border skirmishes
between Mexican revolutionaries and
American landholders, essentially.
What kinds of materials
were available
that helped you understand
the period?
>> Winston Groom: Oh,
there's tons of it.
It's not very much read.
You know there's a
great big war going
on in Europe during
this period; 1916.
That was the First World War.
But the Americans had an army
down there of some sort --
not a huge army --
under General Pershing
and his assistant was a Lieutenant
George S Patton that made a name
for himself in World War II.
And of course there's a
great deal on General Patton,
a great deal on General Pershing.
General Patton's diary
is terrific on that area.
But I threw in some other
people just for the hell of it;
Ambrose Bierce who was a crusty
old guy who wrote something called
"The Devil's Dictionary."
>> Colson Whitehead: Yeah it's --
>> Winston Groom: And
he was down there
and nobody knows what
happened to him.
There's many versions,
but I've got him --
I'll tell you what happened to him.
[laughter] I made it up.
That's good.
>> Audie Cornish: But one thing is,
when I was reading it
then I wasn't sure whether
to trust this character
that I was reading.
I was like, "Did he
make this one up?
Is this a real person?
How should I feel about this?"
What's your view on kind of taking
poetic license with the [inaudible]?
>> Winston Groom: I got you
thinking about it didn't I?
>> Audie Cornish: Yeah, you did.
[laughter]
>> Winston Groom: That's
the way to do it.
I -- you know, once I get
these people in there --
there was the old cowboy actor,
Tom Mix, and he was just rumored
to have been there as a -- some
kind of guy with Ambrose Bierce.
There's no factual proof of
it, but that's the good thing
about doing fiction and
I've done enough nonfiction
in the last 20 years.
That's all I've written is history.
It's fun to be able to
play with the characters,
so long as you don't get
them out of character,
and I tried not to do that.
I tried to -- for instance,
John Reed was down there
and he was a famous journalist who
became a communist and was exiled
from this country and went over
to cover the Russian Revolution
and he died there and
is buried there
with all the famous communists.
But he was down there
covering that revolution.
So, I sort of put them all
in a pot and mixed them up
and see how they came out.
Sometimes it's like a cement mixer
and sometimes it's
like a smoothie mixer.
[laughter] It's all good stuff.
>> Audie Cornish: I sort of have
the opposite problem with your book,
where I thought; oh this is going --
I thought this was
going to deviate more
from the history than it really did.
In fact, it felt actually
super grounded in the history.
And I just had a question;
when you're writing you
are world building, right?
But when you're writing history,
that world is built already.
So, how do you decide like;
okay, what's going to exist
and what's not going
to exist in this world?
>> Colson Whitehead:
Well, I had a few ruled,
I mean before the book takes
off into alternative histories.
I want to have that first section
be as realistic as possible.
>> Audie Cornish: And this
is life on the plantation?
>> Colson Whitehead: Yeah, and so it
is very brutal, as you were saying,
because that's the way
the plantation system was.
And the more research I did,
the more horrified I got
as I was reading it with an adult
perspective on the violence.
Just to pay tribute to my
nameless ancestors who went
through the system, lived
and died in Louisiana
or Florida or Georgia, who knows.
Most of my family history
doesn't go back before --
it wasn't traceable -- before 1900.
I wanted to make it as
realistic as possible and then --
also for just everyone who
went through that, you know,
terrible experience
before I started playing
with history, playing it straight.
And I guess -- and then once
things are altered my rule was;
I'll stick to -- I won't
stick to the facts,
but I'll stick to the truth.
And so as the conversation
about slavery and race
in America gets larger
and larger chapter
to chapter I was moving
historical events around in order
to get to a larger truth.
And so, you know, we're
talking about --
>> Winston Groom: Like what
[inaudible] sometimes you've got
to lie a little bit
to tell the truth.
>> Colson Whitehead: Sure, yeah --
and the ability to make things up.
Historians, hopefully are playing
it straight, and then sometimes --
you know the fun of the
fiction writer is being able
to break the rules.
>> Audie Cornish: It's interesting
to hear you say, "Get to the truth,"
because I think with both of
these periods that you've tackled;
the sort of last throws
of American West mythology
and the many ways the story
of slavery has been written
and then rewritten and interpreted
depending on who's writing it.
Kind of what is the truth, right?
Like as you're deciding; how
much do you police yourself
for a modern lens, right?
When you're looking back.
>> Winston Groom: Well,
I think you --
it comes down to me
to believability.
If you get people to believe
it then you've got a story.
For instance, when I wrote "Forest
Gump" I didn't know what I was doing
and I got to the point where I had
him playing football for Coach Paul
"Bear" Bryant at the University
of Alabama and I thought,
"If they will believe that a
perfect idiot could play football
for 'Bear' Bryant [laughter]
they'll believe anything."
So, that was -- I said, "I gotcha.
[laughter] I'll do what I want to."
But it's the same way with this,
I just tried to keep the
characters in character.
A lot of characters in my
story who are nobody --
I mean they're not well known
or historical figures --
and those are the main
characters, which is, I think,
why I differentiate what I did
and what is normally
called historical fiction.
Most of the characters --
development of the characters is
an ongoing thing between these --
mainly Arthur, the
son of the old man,
Shaughnessy the rich railroad
baron and his grandchildren,
this is his kids that
have been kidnapped
and he's not ready for the trail.
He's a guy from Boston who is a
butterfly collector and he has
to undergo a lot of tough stuff --
and we see it all along the way --
before he finally faces
down General Poncho Villa
to get his kids back,
and he outdraws him.
And it's that kind of thing that
I think it just keeps a reader --
When I do this I know how to do
it because I've done it a lot
of novels before I was a historian,
or a historical writer anyway,
and you've just got to keep the
story moving and you keep the reader
on the edge to say something is
going to happen here pretty soon.
And then after it happens they
go back to being comfortable.
As soon as they get comfortable
I make it uncomfortable
for them again.
>> Audie Cornish: [laughs]
And for you Colson Whitehead,
I mean when you take apart something
to put it back together you
learn new things from it.
And in trying to understand
this period what did you --
how did it change the way you
thought of the runaway story?
>> Colson Whitehead:
Well, I think, you know,
it definitely did in
the first section.
I was trying to make a
psychologically rich sort
of plausible account of
plantation life, you know,
for me as someone writing in
2015, I was writing last year.
I think we have an idea of the
100 person plantation from movies,
you know, obviously there are --
you could be a slave in a single
brownstone in Baltimore working
for a family or one of two
slaves on a small farm.
So, for me it was -- I had my
own different interpretation
of history before I started.
Sometimes you want to get
infected with other people's take
on the subject, sometimes you don't.
I am --
>> Audie Cornish: Although, when
you use the word infected I'm going
to assume that you don't -- [laughs]
>> Colson Whitehead:
It sort of depends.
This time it was like, "Oh, I
haven't read 'Beloved' in 25 years.
I haven't read 'The
Known World' in 14 years.
I'll go back."
And the story of "Beloved"
again I was just like --
after 30 pages it's
like, I'm screwed.
You can't beat Toni Morrison
[laughter] obviously.
>> Audie Cornish: It's confirmed.
>> Colson Whitehead: Duh.
So, all I can do is hope that,
you know, I have something,
I have a unique take that
I can add to our idea
of what slave literature is or,
you know, plantation depictions;
no matter what you write.
>> Audie Cornish: But
what was that idea, right?
I mean, for me when I
read the book I thought
that you took us inside the minds
of images we are familiar with.
For instance, the image of
a hanging before a crowd
and there are all those faces.
Right? The black bodies hanging,
white faces looking into the camera,
and in one of these chapters
of the book you kind of take us
into a community that would
have held such an event.
Were you trying to get
us to think of some point
of views maybe that
we don't normally?
>> Colson Whitehead: Well,
I mean I don't think I --
you know the depiction of
the lynching in the book,
which happens once a week as a sort
of entertainment for this town,
isn't historically accurate.
They weren't weekly gatherings, but
the idea -- but the truth is real.
They were, you know, planned
entertainment sometimes.
You would have the whole
town, bring out the kids,
and watch your scapegoat black
male lynched, burned alive,
take pictures, pose for the
camera, you know, you would --
there are big collections
of lynching postcards.
"I wish you were here," you know,
"had a nice time at this lynching."
And so I'm making it, you
know, into weekly events,
but I'm not pushing it that far.
Whenever I thought I was
being a little too brutal
on the page I would go back to
the research and realize that,
no actually I was sticking to,
you know, to a version of reality.
You know I'm one person
writing a book for a year,
slave masters were watching their
fathers coming up with, you know,
all sorts of sadistic
things for decades
and decades to keep people in line.
And I can't really compete with
all the stuff that they thought
up because it was their job to
come up with these sort of --
to keep the brutal system in place.
>> Audie Cornish: You know, both of
you have done stints as journalists;
[laughs] Colson Whitehead as a
TV critic for the Village Voice.
Is that correct?
>> Colson Whitehead: That's true.
>> Audie Cornish: And
Winston Groom you were
at the Washington Star Newspaper.
>> Winston Groom: I was
at the Washington Star.
>> Audie Cornish: So, how does that
affect how you go about your work?
What is it about that
particular discipline
that you -- still sticks with you?
>> Winston Groom: It opens a door.
It doesn't open it all the way.
And I know that when I decided
to leave the newspaper I did
probably the bravest thing
in my life.
I went to the editor and
said, "I'm going to resign.
I'm going to write a book"
and it was because I knew
that if I failed I
would be too embarrassed
to come back to the papers.
I got [inaudible].
>> Audie Cornish: You wouldn't
be the first journalist
who had made such an attempt.
[laughs]
>> Winston Groom: But I
started trying to write it
in Washington and, you know, we had
-- we couldn't even clean up a quote
and I was beginning to feel guilty.
And Washington's a very
political town, but --
and I'm starting to write fiction.
I said, I can't do it here.
So, I went to New York where
there were fellow writers.
But I think the newspaper business
certainly teaches you clarity
of thought.
It teaches you clarity of language.
It teaches you gravity.
But the finesse that you have to do
to translate that into a novel is --
it's a juggling act
and you learn it.
I learned it, but it took a
while before it didn't sound
like newspaper copy.
Suddenly it starts -- zing.
And that's fun.
>> Audie Cornish: I was amused about
the TV angle of your gig because,
this book in particular,
feels episodic.
The way it's structured each
chapter is in a specific state
as this runaway slave is
travelling along their path.
And I wondered if [laughs]
sometimes you sort
of have an eye towards
narrative in that way.
>> Colson Whitehead:
No, not so much.
I mean, you know, when I was a TV
critic it was early 90s and I'm
like -- it was really
embarrassing to be a TV critic.
Now people are recapping
[laughter] and it's like,
you really engaged the pop culture.
Me, it was like the only gig I could
get and no one else wanted to do it.
[laughter] And when I
watch TV now I'm very glad
to be a passive spectator and not
to have sort of grand theories
about why things are working.
>> Audie Cornish: Yeah, it had a
"Twilight Zone" feel
[laughs] a little bit.
>> Winston Groom: I have a question.
Can I ask a question?
>> Audie Cornish: Yeah, please do.
>> Winston Groom: Colson,
what -- how --
these fugitive slaves,
how were they received?
And how were they -- ?
>> Colson Whitehead: Sorry?
>> Winston Groom: I say, the
fugitive slave involved --
I mean, would they have a trade when
they got out of the slave states?
>> Colson Whitehead: Sure.
No. I mean --
>> Winston Groom: Were
they received nicely or --
>> Audie Cornish: This is a question
about how the slave narratives
were published and received.
>> Colson Whitehead: Yeah, well
they were political tracts.
So, the ones from the 1850s
they were printed to get people
to abhor the slave system.
And so printed by white
abolitionists in Massachusetts
and New York and disseminated as
testimony about the brutal system
in the South and, you
know, there was --
it became ammunition to end slavery.
The ones collected in the 1930s,
apart from getting people back
to work, you know, I imagine part
of the impulse was just to preserve.
You know nobody was keeping
track of the slave experience,
you know, prior to this century.
People were dying off and so you
want to capture it before it's lost.
And I'm particularly
[laughs] very glad.
>> Winston Groom: That answered it.
>> Audie Cornish: Now this is
the portion of our afternoon
where we're going to take
questions from the audience.
We have two microphones in the
center aisles here and we'll sort
of ping pong back and
forth between the two.
>> Winston Groom: Do we
ask ourselves questions?
>> Audie Cornish: Let's see.
There you go.
>> Yes, there we go.
I was just wondering about the
cross cultural aspects of both
of your books in the sense
of covering Mexican events
from a different perspective.
And also just, you know, the nature
of the Underground Railroad
was a story that's of interest,
not just to African
American communities
or just told during
Black History Month,
but it's of interest
to a wider audience.
How do you honor the integrity of
the cultures that you're writing
about and, you know,
talk about that,
but also broaden what you're
writing about to a wider audience.
>> Audie Cornish: Right.
Winston Groom, in your book you were
seeing many chapters from the point
of view of General Poncho Villa
and from some of the people
who are working with him as
revolutionaries, although they seem
to question their role over time.
>> Winston Groom: Yeah, well
I mean I don't do points
of view by chapters.
I did it by scenes.
And so I've got a lot of
people doing a lot of things
and thinking a lot of
things at the same time.
It's a literary device.
I remember once I was
stuck on my first book.
I had a scene; it was too
long, too many people talking.
And I went to see a friend
of mine, James Jones,
who had written "From Here to
Eternity," and among other books,
and he was working
on his final novel,
he was to die in a year or so.
But anyway, I said, "Yeah, I just
can't seem to get this right."
He said, "I tell you what, I just
had that problem this morning.
Instead of having one character
think what the other character's
thinking about, have the other
character think what the other
character might be
thinking about him too."
So, you have two or three things
all going on at one time and I'll --
but it keeps the reader on their
toes and I mean everybody --
I give everybody a point
of view, just about.
That can be confusing, but I think
it's useful as far as the follow
of the story because you want that
story to punch forward all the time.
>> Audie Cornish: Colson Whitehead,
what kind of cross-cultural --
>> Colson Whitehead: Yeah, I --
you know the young gentleman asked
about the cross-cultural stories.
I guess I don't think about
my work in that sort of way,
in the same way I don't necessarily
think of this as a historical novel.
It's just a novel.
And so I'm not thinking
so much about audience
or what I'm transmitting to --
from my culture or onto
different audiences,
a white audience or whatever.
You know I'm trying to figure
out something about the world
in each book, or something about
myself, and hopefully do it
in a way that's artistically
cohesive
that other people can
come along for the ride
and I always feel fortunate
when that works out.
--
>> Hello there.
Thank you for writing your books
and my question for both of you is;
of the historical characters in your
books, do you have a favorite one?
>> Colson Whitehead:
Yeah, I don't have any --
>> Audie Cornish: The question,
just for everyone here;
their favorite character,
historical character, in their book.
>> Colson Whitehead: Yeah, I mean
I don't have any characters based
directly on people.
Cora, as our protagonist,
is, you know,
partially inspired
by Harriot Jacobs.
>> Yeah.
>> Colson Whitehead: She's a
woman who wrote a slave narrative
about leaving her house at age
-- you know, in her teenage years
and hid in an attic for seven
years before she got passage
out of North Carolina.
And the female slaves -- you
know, the dilemma she described
in her narrative motivated me
to have a female protagonist.
When you're a female slave, when
you hit 14, puberty, you're supposed
to pump out kids -- more
kids means more slaves
and more slaves means more cotton
and more money and you become --
you're prey to your master's
desires, desires of other people
on the plantation, and it seemed
compelling material to explore.
And so while Cora's not
based on Harriet Jacobs,
definitely reading Harriet Jacobs'
narrative 30 years ago in college,
you know, sort of bubbled in the
back of my mind for many years
and was a partial inspiration
for the book.
>> Audie Cornish: You have a lot to
choose from in terms of characters.
>> Winston Groom: I what?
>> Audie Cornish: In terms
of characters you have
a lot to choose from.
Is there a historical figure
that became your favorite
as you were writing?
>> Winston Groom: Well, I
kind of like the contrast
between Ambrose Bierce, the
"Devil's Dictionary" guy,
and John Reed, who was a communist.
And as they go along the trail
they're constantly arguing politics
and that's -- it's a sideshow
in a way, but it gets --
it still moves the story forward
because you're building
the characters.
So, the reader, at the end, they
will say, "Well, I kind of know
that fellow and I liked him."
And what happened to him,
you don't want to know.
>> Audie Cornish: [laughs] Yeah,
I have to say, towards the end
of the book various
people are dispatched
in increasingly creative ways.
[laughter] I did not know how
many ways there were to die
in the West until I read this book.
>> Winston Groom: It's
very Shakespearean.
>> Audie Cornish: [laughing]
Yes it is.
It is.
>> Winston Groom: A lot of murders.
A lot of blood that won't
wash off hands and so forth.
Yeah. [laughter] Audie Cornish: Mam.
Winston Groom: Perfect
night for a murder.
>> My question is for Winston Groom.
Knowing Birmingham, Alabama and
having visited there a long time,
I'm wondering to what extent
growing up in Alabama and --
has influenced your writing and
also where you went to college.
I loved hearing about
everything that happened after it,
but I think those two
factors often underlie some
of the writing that I've read.
>> Audie Cornish: When
it comes to education
in Alabama isn't there
really only one answer?
>> Winston Groom: Roll tide.
>> Audie Cornish: Are you
allowed to give any other answer?
[laughter]
>> Winston Groom: Well,
I'd say I went
to boys' military school growing up
and then I went to the University
of Alabama and I was lucky enough
-- I believe my sophomore year --
to have an instructor
called Hudson Strode,
who had taught my mother dramatics
and literature back in the 1920s.
And he had a small class
that he had of writers.
It was above the library with
big velvet drapes and a bust
of Liabee [phonetic spelling]
in the corner and a long table.
And everybody sat around
in that old Socratic method
of criticizing everybody
else's work.
And that was -- it was
useful to that extent and --
but when I was in college
I was the editor of --
first the literary magazine and then
the real prize was a humor magazine,
and I thought I was very well
equipped to go up to New York
and become the editor of Esquire
at that point or something.
And Doctor Strode -- I had to go
to Vietnam first with the Army.
And I got out of that and
I went up to New York,
he had got me appointments, and they
were all very nice and every one
of them said the same thing, "but
you don't have any experience."
And I thought, "Well, I edited
my college literary magazine.
Isn't that experience?"
No. So, finally one
fellow, Don Erickson --
who later became the
editor and chief
of the New York Times Magazine -- I
asked him, "Well, what am I supposed
to do to get this experience?"
He said, "Why don't you
go work on a newspaper?"
And -- okay.
I'd never even thought about that.
I mean we had -- journalism
was not really a subject
that was taught well at the
University of Alabama in those days.
As a matter of fact, Joe
Namath majored in journalism.
[laughter] And the funny thing
was, when he got off the plane
in Miami all the sports writers
said, "Well, Joe what did you major
in at Alabama, basket weaving?"
He said, "No, the same
thing you majored in."
[laughter] But in any case I was
lucky enough to get on at the Star.
I spent 10 years there
and finally I said,
"If I don't get a break here I'm
going to wind up with a, you know,
mortgage and a car payment."
And I said, [dissenting noise]
"I'm going to give this a shot."
So, that's basically -- that's
the short history of my life.
>> Audie Cornish: [laughs] Colson
Whitehead we should ask the same
with you.
I think we learn a lot from
writers in terms of the early years
in which they form their identity.
So, high school?
College?
>> Colson Whitehead: Yeah, well I
think in terms of writing I wanted
to become a writer from reading
Marvell Comics and Stephen King
and Arthur C Clarke,
"Twilight Zone" --
watching "Twilight Zone"
and "The Outer Limits,"
and wanting to make things up.
And I think later on in college
-- I was a freshman at Harvard --
I started reading Garcia Marquez
and Bora Hays, [phonetic spelling]
and Beckett and was
introduced to a different way
of using fantasy; fantastic effects.
You know different way of dealing
with vampires and werewolves
than say, the blasted
landscape of "Waiting for Godot"
but using fantasy in different ways.
And I think definitely with
this book and some other books
of mine I've been, you know,
still drawing from all the fantasy
literature I read when I was,
you know, in fifth grade and
sixth grade and find inspiration
and find different ways of
deforming reality to get
at that larger truth we
were talking about earlier.
>> Audie Cornish: We can
feel you trying your hand
at each genre like -- [laughs]
>> Colson Whitehead: Sure, yeah.
>> Audie Cornish: It's zombie time.
You know? [laughs]
>> Colson Whitehead: No I mean --
>> Audie Cornish: I feel like --
>> Colson Whitehead: You
keep writing, you know,
and I like poker --
I wrote a poker book.
If you keep writing I guess you get
enough time to address things you
like [laughs] and interests you.
So --
>> Audie Cornish: We
have a question.
>> This question is
for Mister Whitehead.
About your novel "The Intuitionist"
and I'm curious where the idea
for that novel came from
and particularly what was it
about the image of an elevator
that is so central to that novel?
Kind of what is the symbolism of
that and where did that come from?
-- --
>> Colson Whitehead: Sure, yeah.
>> Audie Cornish: Do you want
me to try and give the synopsis?
>> Colson Whitehead: Oh no.
Yeah. [laughter] I can do it.
It's -- the question is about, with
"The Intuitionist," how it evolved.
Well, I'd written a book two
years before and everyone hated it
and it got, you know, 25 rejections.
So, I figured I'll do
something different
and maybe do a book with a plot.
People like that.
People like plots in books.
[laughter] And so I
was going to take off
from a detective novel structure
and came up with the idea of what
if an elevator inspector --
someone who inspects elevators --
has to become a criminal inspector
and solve a criminal case?
So, I went to the library
to see what kind
of skills an elevator inspector
would bring to the criminal case,
and the answer was none because
they [laughter] inspect elevators.
And so the crime in the book
became an elevator crime
and then I had to build a world.
And so I figured if they
were -- it's an election --
taken off from the
detective story --
it's an election year
in the department.
So, there's sort of
republicans and democrats
and that became the
intuitionists and empiricists --
progressives and conservatives.
If there's a school where they
learn how to do it there has
to be some sort of
academic in fighting.
And so there's sort of
this building of a world,
like what's their school like?
Who's the main theorist
behind intuitionism?
And each time I would solve a
problem I'd have to, you know --
I'd have more questions I'd have
to answer, but it was usually
about building a world in a real
kind of science fiction kind of way.
>> Hi. This is for Mister Whitehead,
although I love "Forest Gump."
I always will.
I'm like Audie, I read the
book, the first chapter,
and put it down for multiple
days because it was so intense.
And the way you build
Cora out and her --
she's the main character throughout.
What was your intention?
What do you want the reader
to leave with other than pain?
>> Colson Whitehead:
Well, I think there's more
than pain going on with Cora.
How do you -- you know, I think
hopefully when you're reading
that first section you're
thinking, "How could this go on?
How did this brutality -- ?"
>> Right.
>> Colson Whitehead: How did the
country countenance such depravity?
And then you think of;
how did they survive?
And how could any human being
endure such horrors intact?
And then once you set that
up, what does it take to take
that first step off the
plantation to freedom?
Would I have been able to do that?
To find that power within
myself to run North?
I mean, you'd like to
think that you're --
have that kind of strength,
but most people didn't.
The system was so brutal
you couldn't try it.
If you did try it you
got caught, lose a foot.
So, what kind of character can
go through what Cora goes through
and has that courage to run North?
And I think it starts there and in
that first section there are a few
moments where I say, "The human part
of her outpaces the
slave part of her."
And that human part of her is what
animates her journey northward
and then as we get to these
different situations her movement
to a different kind of freedom.
So, I think that sort of
answers your question,
but gets at my intent with Cora.
>> Audie Cornish: We could
ask a similar question of you
because I think one of
the things that happens
in this particular story is that
you see the way General Poncho Villa
operates as he moves through
the North from town to town
in really brutal ways in the
pursuit of his revolution.
And what did you want people
to take away from that?
Because in some ways it definitely
undermines the hero aspect
of him, right?
>> Winston Groom: Well,
I don't think it --
what I have read about him,
and there's a great deal
that's been written about him,
and probably 40 or
60 percent is false.
I mean, it's just totally
contradictory.
There've been a couple of good
books about him and I listed them
in the -- somewhere in
the acknowledgements.
But he was -- that whole
country was brutal then.
It -- I mean it was a
horrible place to live.
The Apaches and --
brutalized the people
and they had learned
from the Apaches.
And Poncho Villa one
time -- and this was --
I presume it was a
true story -- he --
somebody bet him that he
couldn't shoot a man's eye out
and he shot the man's eye out
and then he felt sorry about it
so he gave his wife 100 pesos.
That's brutality, but
they were rough times.
And I mean he'd have you
skinned alive and so forth.
General Fiaro, [phonetic
spelling] he was known
for some very bad deeds.
They called him "the
butcher" and that wasn't just
on the Villa side either, it
was on the government's side.
There was no quarter [inaudible].
>> Audie Cornish: Question
over here.
>> Yes, my question is
for Colson Whitehead.
I just wanted to say
I loved your book.
I thought it was brilliantly
written, but I was kind of confused
and really baffled by the ending and
I really didn't know what happened.
I know you may not want
to give away the ending,
but I was wondering what actually
happened to the slave hunter
and what ultimately happened to
Cora because I didn't quite get it.
>> Colson Whitehead: Sure.
Thanks for reading.
It hasn't come up a lot.
I think most people have come to the
round reckoning with Cora's story.
I will say this about Cora;
even if she gets to --
in an alternative story -- gets to
Massachusetts and wins a lottery
and wins three billion dollars,
she's still an African
American woman in 1850
in America, which is a racist place.
So, what is her best case scenario
when she lives in a racist country.
So, you'll be able to get there.
Maybe that can be -- work, I hope.
>> Audie Cornish: Yeah, but
it's an interesting question
because if you're talking about
brutal periods of history,
this is where you come up against
the rules of these worlds, right?
In terms of history there's
only so far you're going to get
in terms of these characters.
>> Colson Whitehead: Yes.
I mean --
>> Audie Cornish: Necessarily
have a happily ever after.
She'll have something, but it's
not a tied bow the way we would all
like I think.
>> Thank you.
>> First of all, thank
you both for your work
because it is work and
it's very grueling.
And my question -- it's a
statement and a question I guess.
Your notions about the depictions
of history and the implications
of that are such that neither of
your books can be merely a book.
They simply are not.
And because of that depiction
of everyone I'm wondering
about the role, Mister Whitehead,
of resistance in your book
because the narrative is
that -- as you said --
people rolled over, basically.
And that is not quite an
accurate interpretation
of the truth, if you will.
The truth is that there were over
400 rebellions on the Atlantic Ocean
and the Amistad wasn't
the only truth.
The truth is that there were a
million acts of resistance every day
because you don't have
to run away to resist
and your Cora did not
grow up in a vacuum.
She was nurtured, and that energy
of taking that step was nurtured
and was affirmed so
that resistance --
she resisted and that resistance was
rooted in community and in values
about "I don't think so."
So, in your -- I don't know --
>> Audie Cornish: Well,
we can let him answer.
Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Colson Whitehead: I agree.
It's not -- it was a
statement that I agree with.
So --
>> Audie Cornish: Did you have
a question to add to this?
>> In your next work
are you going to talk
about resistance explicitly
and how that went on?
>> Colson Whitehead: Probably not.
Will I address that in my next book?
Probably not.
I, you know, when I'm done
with a topic I like to move
on to the next one and the next
book takes place in a 1960s Harlem.
It has a different sort
of striving in there.
But you -- but I think
you're totally right
about our daily rebellions,
whether it's, you know,
in contemporary life; how do we
keep going and how do we stand
up to the forces that
raid against us?
Or 20 years ago; how do
we figure out systems
that help us get it through the day?
And, you know, hopefully
in Cora's story
and in the supporting cast you
get different kinds of stepping up
and different ways of
overthrowing tyranny.
Thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Audie Cornish: Unfortunately
that is our last question
because we're towards the end.
I think it's a good question
to end on because it gets
at the idea of responsibility.
Whenever you're tackling history
you embrace the responsibility
of interpreting that time.
I want to thank everyone
for coming and I hope
that you'll consider donating
to the National Book
Festival via their App.
There's also information
in your program.
Colson Whitehead; author of
"The Underground Railroad."
Thank you.
>> Colson Whitehead: Thank you guys.
[applause]
>> Audie Cornish: And Winston
Groom; his book is called "El Paso."
Thank you.